you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 21
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at another key rook and pawn endgame the
last two videos in this playlist where
rook and pawn related we had a look at
the Lucena position the Philidor
position and now this one here which
does not have any specific name
connected to it this is a topic I
covered nearly seven years ago I'm
revisiting it specifically for this
playlist it without question has its
place here and this time around it will
be much more comprehensive now the key
features with this endgame are as
follows
we're working with one side having an
extra pawn big surprise right we've seen
this before we've seen a position filled
our position one side has an extra pawn
however we are now working with an extra
pawn that is one square away from
queening in other words we're working
with a seventh rank pawn
also take note of the rook position both
rook positions
the stronger sides rook is in front of
the pond the defending sides rook is
behind the pond behind the passed pond
we can very easily see this type of an
endgame spring about the pond
a little bit further back it's every
movement is observed by both rooks and
eventually we get to a point where the
pond could go no further
it's stuck something needs to happen
with the rook now soon enough I will
share what to do from this position and
what not to do but before I dive into
any of that I'd like to emphasize the
following and that is in rook and pawn
endgames
rooks tend to be optimally placed behind
past pawns that is the current state of
the defending sides rook in this
position now why what is a reason for
this well let me see how I can help let
me strip the board of the Kings for a
moment and I'm going to throw some
numbers at you that at least initially
you're likely to be confused but I will
clear up the confusion let me throw some
numbers at you and see if you can make
out what they mean
are you ready this is a 10/10 position
this one here 11 9 this one here 12 8
and finally this position is a 13-7 now
what in the world am I talking about if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
or maybe rewind it and watch this that
part again see if you can figure it out
I'm just going to dive right into it
what do those numbers reference what do
they mean
10 10 position right I'm talking about
the mobility of both rooks the one who
is behind the pond versus the one who is
in front currently each rook has 10
options as soon as that pond makes a
move it changes the rook that is behind
the pond it's mobility has just
increased by 1 and the one who is in
front it has decreased by one and this
continues with every step of the pond
until we reach a position where the rook
that is behind the pond now has 13
options and the one who is in front only
has 7 now there will be plenty of cases
where this is still best we're going to
we're going to see that soon enough but
I just wanted to at least give you a
reason as to why there tends to be this
idea of you know the rook being
optimally placed behind passed pawns we
can see just factoring in the mobility
of each rook as that pawn moves one rook
increases in mobility another decreases
okay
generally speaking we like to have the
more options the better right
anyhow I just wanted to give some
support for that line about rook being
optimally placed behind a passed pawn
now this position right here what to do
whose move is it is White's move and
they play King to f3 now what to do as
black one may think to go in this
direction to hunt down the pawn let's
try that
King f6 that's no good
King f6 allows the rook to move with
check safely right
there's no King takes rook here and
after the King moves the pawn promotes
that's no good okay so maybe black says
well I'm not going to go here because
you could go here with check therefore
I'll kind of walk a tightrope rook right
here that way you can't give a
successful check I'll just take you and
then take the pawn next however there's
an issue with this as well after King to
f7 the rook can still move out of the
pawns way going to h7 preparing to
promote and if rook takes pawn now we
have a skewer tactic check King moves
there goes the rook ouch what does this
mean it means that from this position
the King must stay the black King after
King the f3
the black king must stay put on the g7
square or the h7 Square these are two
save squares for the black king are they
the only save squares they're not there
are four others there are a total of six
squares that act as a safe haven for the
black King where there isn't this type
of white rook move to either skewer the
black King or give check to the black
King these two as well as these four
total of six squares are safe ground for
the black King let me just shift the
position here if the King is over here
white being on move in this position
some check is not going to be good
enough because the King can step up and
be close enough to track down the pawn
ok so these are the these four and these
two over here are really the key squares
to be familiar with these are safe
ground for the defending sides King okay
this is really all you need to know as
far as where the defending sides King
ought to be again we're working with a
pawn that is just a single step away
from queening staying put on these two
right here is perfect all black needs to
do here is focus on the rook what to do
exactly with the rook well let's see
black from this position it should be
noted can draw and the drawing method is
quite simple after king to f3 you keep
the King right here he's in a good spot
g7 h7 there are no tricks with the white
rook as long as the King stays on one of
these two right now all we do with black
with the rook is stay trained on this
pawn the White King can approach and all
we do is keep pressure on the phone
until a certain point and what is that
certain point
right now as soon as white tries to
let's say have a bit of a changing of
the gaurd right for all of these moves
here by the white king it's the rook
who's the one guarding the pond
protecting the pond what white wants to
have have happened here is the rook now
move so that the pawn can push through
now that the king is there defending the
pawn the rook is in a position to next
move and then white can push through as
soon as as soon as the King defends the
pond that's when you give check King b7
rook check King a6 we come right back
over we just happen to be giving check
we're also putting pressure on the pawn
in this case King b6 is he still is the
King still defending the pond yes we
need to give check the king is defending
the pawn that's when we give check rook
b1 King c6 we get right back over and
put pressure on the pawn king to b5 we
don't have to give check here we can
simply state rained on this pawn and
this is the drawing resource what it's
coming down to with this endgame is that
there is no good place for the white
King to hide where is a place where he
can hide from these checks there isn't
any place he can hide
he's just a moment away from hiding when
he gets to the b7 square if we just play
rook to a2 this would be a way to lose
because the rook can now move and we
could give a check another check another
check but now the king eventually just
dodges the checks and white will be able
to push through so this is the key idea
as soon as the king is in a position to
defend the pawn
that's when we start to insert some
checks and when the king is not
defending the pawn we just get right
back over and keep pressure on it
and we will have no issue in drawing
this position type
no I'm showing this with a rook pawn let
me also just shift this over for a
moment this can be a knight pawn that
we're working with and I'd like to
highlight what the key squares would be
in this position these two would be the
same safe-haven squares for the King
would be g7 and h7 still and if somehow
the King could get to these there would
there would not be any rook tricks
involved like the skewer tactic I showed
initially let me just highlight that
again if King f3 and King f7 this little
trick is not available as long as the
king is sting on one of these two or if
he's a little bit closer to the pawn on
one of these four so these are the key
six squares from this position working
with a knight pawn working with the rook
pawn we'd be working with these six
squares okay
now I'd like to start to add just a
little bit to this endgame this is this
is the basic this is this is the bulk of
it okay this drawing method but I want
to add just a few more pawns to this end
game okay suppose we have this position
right here and whites on move pushes the
pawn what must you do in this position
as black if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video what move would you player
what move should you play in this
position okay the move here there is an
only move and it must be King to e4
so I know initially I was highlighting
these is this the only safe squares but
you know in more practical
positions there's more pawns involved
okay that was just like the bare-bones
type of endgame that I was showing but
adding some more pawns there are some
other safe squares for the king and it's
ones related to hiding behind your own
pawns notice there is not some rook move
here with check anymore on a rook to e8
rook to e8 move we're able to just take
the pawn in this case so these key ideas
are available with more pawns involved
you know don't be just so fixated on oh
these are the only safe squares no more
pawns involved you can use your own
pawns as shelter for your King now
you'll also have to be just a little bit
careful let me show you this position
right here where I eliminate a pawn
after the move a 7 you can hide for a
move here in this position with King to
e4 however there's now a very nice move
I wonder if you can spot it for white
you ready here's the move f4 now what if
pawn takes pawn now this will hit with
check allowing white to promote next in
white will go on to win this endgame
this pawn will be hunted down shortly
and if King takes pawn similarly the
king is now exposed rook check and then
the pawn promotes next so I just wanted
to highlight that there are situations
where you can hide behind your own pawns
but at the same time you are also
vulnerable as we are seeing here with
the move f4 to be stripped of your pawn
shield with the f4 move okay what more
to share
some of you
you know I'm sharing this with you you
may want to take it a step deeper and
you may be curious about this position
and you may ask well okay I know that
this is a draw this is again a
bare-bones type of end game this is you
know the the basic let's just say
suppose we added another pawn to this
position will it be a win well let's see
let me add just to this position right
here and I just have a few more examples
suppose we add this bond right here a
bishop on now not just any bishop on I'm
not talking about the bishop on that's
closest to this this pawn right here
both the one that's further away so this
guy right here is this a win it is let's
see why let's just play out a few moves
here f4 rook a to King f3 giving some
checks eventually you could dodge the
checks notice the black rook doesn't
want to ever capture the pawn as this
allows the rook to move and light will
be promoting soon
so what more to do the rook could go
back to a-1 but now this pawn continues
to move eventually some more checks are
given and they run out and now we have
f6 and now black is in a tough spot
right because don't forget these key
squares right after f6 is played Auto
this is a poison pawn you take this pawn
it allows check and then push so you
can't take that bishop on can you so
what can you do if you go here light
continues to push and will push next to
Queen
the only other try King f7 but he's not
in that safe haven area this allows rook
h8 preparing to just promote right so
rook takes pawn fall for a skewer
there's no way around it the short story
here is that the bishop on will be
enough to well white will be able to win
if you're working with the bishop on
satisfied with that let's take it just
one step further as a close to this
video to this concept here are there any
other pawns that we can add to this
position right here where it will be a
draw
yes what pawns a knight pawn and or
excuse me a knight pawn or a rook pawn
again we're talking about this area over
here for further away from this past
pawn if we're working with a night pawn
or a rook pawn this will be a drum now
why is that the case you may ask well
it's because that the King is perfectly
happy being a block hater of a knight
pawn right consider these two key
squares g7 this pawn could only go so
far and the King is
fine he's not pushed away from these two
key squares by a night bun nor is he
chased away by a rook pawn as an example
just playing through with the rook pawn
some all we have to do is black is just
bounce back and forth we don't have to
even give checks just bounce back and
forth on these two there's a little
check thrown in okay fine we go to this
square it doesn't really matter one of
these two is sufficient the King may try
to come over here and what do we do as
soon as the King defends the pawn we
give check we get over put more pressure
on the pawn here we happen to be giving
check again we just stay trained on the
pond and this is the drawing resource so
there is another pawn that we could add
to this type of an endgame where it
still holds as a draw and that is again
ones where it is a rook pawn or even a
knight pawn and the reason for that is
because the King is just as happy being
a block hater of the pawn on g7 or h7
right the knight file or even the rook
file this pawn there isn't a good way to
put it to use okay so these are the key
ideas I maybe took it a little bit well
I don't know if I took it too far but it
was definitely a bit more thorough than
just the the bare bones the first time I
shared it seven years back we could be
adding these pawns to the position this
is a draw you need to be aware of these
key squares and also when we add a
couple pawns to the position there are
these ideas where we can of course and
these are more practical situations
where we can be using our own pawns as
shelter for our King you just don't be
locked into these being the only key
squares there are situations like this
where we can be hiding
behind our own ponds but of course we
also have to be a bit careful we can at
times have this shield the shelter for
our King be removed by some key pawn
moves and that'll set up these little
tactics to give a check and then push
through ok so that's all for this video
feel free to leave any feedback to it in
the comment section below and I will
catch you in the next one that's all for
now take care bye
you